[Musique]
j'ai rapidement compris que le
changement ça ne plaisait pas à tout le
monde et le changement s'était pas
quelque chose qui était naturel qu'il
fallait argumenté qu'il fallait
convaincre qu'il fallait aller au devant
des peurs et des résistances pour
arriver à transformer et pourtant la
transformation l'évolution
l'amélioration je crois fermement que
c'est quelque chose qui est absolument
obligatoire et dont la vitesse en plus
accélère de nos jours la deuxième chance
est que après cette expérience là j'ai
basculé dans une petite usine de
production dans laquelle j'ai eu la
chance d'exercer plein de métiers
différents
depuis le support technique de la supply
chain de la logistique physique j'ai eu
à mener des projets sur des changements
de systèmes d'information sur réductions
de coûts optimisation de flux etc et
tout ça je les menées grâce à des
équipes et j'ai vite compris aussi que
l'équipe c'est la clé de voûte de la
réussite d'un changement il faut
absolument embarquer les acteurs pour
que le changement se fasse de manière
positive
la troisième chose c'est que à ce moment
là j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des
managers qui était plutôt qu'un match au
plus tôt ouvert et qui m'ont aidée en
gagner en maturité
un autonomie qui étaient là quand
j'avais des difficultés qui dépassé mon
champ d'action pour proposer des voies
de solution est donc pour me faire
grandir et enfin j'ai très rapidement
aussi été amené à mener des activités
dans un domaine transnationales
essentiellement sur un axe franco
allemand et j'ai vite compris aussi que
pour engager pour motiver pour faire
avancer des équipes
ben en fait pas pareil quand on est face
à des allemands que quand on est face à
des français il ya des aspects
éminemment culturelle il ya des aspects
qui sont intrinsèques aux individus et
il faut en tenir compte pour pour
réussir donc de cette expérience là je
voulais retenir trois éléments majeurs
que je vais partager avec vous d'abord
vous avez compris ce que j'aime la
production ce que j'aime en production
en premier c'est que quand on est amené
à travailler sur une transformation d'un
atelier d'une ligne de produits la
création de d'une nouvelle façon de
produire quelque chose on est sur un
impact qui est visible on est sur des
moyens physiques
on est sur du tangible et je trouve ça
extrêmement gratifiant la deuxième chose
c'est que en production les relations
humaines sont extrêmement simples ça
peut être musclé
ça peut être directe mais au moins on se
dit les choses et puis après on les fait
la troisième chose c'est que quand vous
mener ce type de projet de changement de
transformation vous êtes amené à la fois
à défendre votre votre sujet votre
budget votre planning face à des
managers qui sont un peu costaud et
chivu challenge mais vous avez aussi à
gérer au quotidien tous les petits
problèmes toutes les petites choses qui
vous arrive sur le bureau
vous avez aussi à dialoguer avec tous
les interlocuteurs locaux
les ouvriers les employés les syndicats
et donc tous à sa demande d'une agilité
intellectuelle que personnellement je
trouve extrêmement stimulante
en fait je crois que ce que je préfère
c'est que quand on crée un atelier où
quand on transforme un atelier de
fabrication ou d'assemblage
on a l'impression de contribuer à
quelque chose qui est plus grand que soi
et qui vous survivre
de cette expérience là j'ai d'après mon
expérience de mes succès et de mes
échecs retenu un certain nombre de
points
d'abord il faut bien préparer ses
dossiers c'est clair il faut aussi
accumulé le savoir au travers des
affaires qu'on a à traiter au fur et à
mesure du temps pour
pouvoir utiliser ce qu'on a déjà eu
comme solution sur des problèmes
nouveaux qui peuvent se produire d'un
projet à l'autre
j'ai coutume de dire aussi que la
richesse nette de la diversité c'est à
dire que l'on n'est pas seul il faut
sortir de ses oeillères d'experts est
allé voir d'autres gens qui ont fait la
même chose ou qui ont fait des choses
complètement différentes
il faut aller discuter il faut aller
prendre des avis différents
pour pouvoir construire quelque chose
qui sera encore plus pertinent quand on
est face à un projet de changement comme
je le disais tout à l'heure tout le
monde n'est pas enthousiaste 1 vous avez
des fans vous avez des opposants passif
et vous avez des opposants actifs il
faut aller les chercher il faut aller là
où il s'en faut pas avoir peur du
conflit faut aller vers eux faut
comprendre quelles sont leurs peurs
quelles sont leurs craintes et ça veut
dire que ben on ne peut pas aller tout
droit il faut aller les chercher là où
ils sont et les ramener sur la voie qui
vous semble être celle du succès je dis
donc souvent que la ligne droite n'est
pas le plus court chemin pour faire tout
ça il faut savoir influencé alors je
veux dire que là dessus j'ai puisé
quelques idées dans un livre je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il soit traduit en français
c'est le livre de fisher et urique qui
s'appelle getting to yes et qui donne un
certain nombre de
certain nombre de règles ou de trucs et
aussi de méthode pour arriver à donner
du sens argumente et apporter des
éléments qui vont permettre aux
différents intervenants de converger
vers la solution qui paraît être la
meilleure et j'ai aussi l'habitude de
rester très calme toute circonstance je
suis connu pour ça même si c'est un gros
gros travail sur soi et qu'on a
quelquefois envie de hurler quand on
vous pose un problème sur la table mais
ça rassure les équipes ça rassure les
gens qui travaillent avec vous de savoir
que vous êtes toujours là toujours calme
et que vous allez proposer de réfléchir
à une solution ensemble là là là
l'ambiance de l'équipe est aussi
importante et maintenir un bien c'est
une ambiance positive
c'est parfois un challenge parce que les
les moments différents dans la tenue
d'un projet font que vous pouvez passer
d'une grande nos forêts a tout à coup de
gros problèmes donc il faut maintenir
cette ambiance positive dans les équipes
ça veut passer par des choses très
simples à ne pas oublier les
anniversaires proposer des petits
déjeuners où chacun amène quelque chose
enfin chaque équipe a sa propre à sa
propre personnalité et il faut la capter
et il faut l'utiliser pour le manager je
crois aussi qu'il faut faire preuve
d'abnégation c'est à dire oublier son
ego se mettre de côté être à l'écouté et
de cette manière là on apprend aussi on
apprend de tout et on apprend sur soi
la seule chose que je ne fais jamais
c'est d'utiliser le fait que je suis une
femme j'ai l'habitude de dire que quand
j'ai passé la la la barrière de
l'entreprise que je suis rentré dans
l'entreprise eh bien je suis un employé
comme un autre et c'est tout le plus
difficile le plus difficile au cours de
ce parcours pour moi ça a été d'abord
d'oser osé poser c'est la presse est le
premier pas c'est la première chose
qu'il faut faire c'est prendre la parole
c'est être capable de défendre une
opinion c'est être capable de défendre
un projet d'une certaine manière ce qui
m'a permis de le faire c'est que j'ai
toujours considéré que je ne parlais pas
un mot non mais que je parler au nom de
mes équipes et que donc je défends donné
leur point de vue j'étais leur porte
parole
et ça c'était bien la deuxième la
deuxième chose c'est qu'en tant que
femme je dois dire que il faut prouver
encore et encore et ça prend du temps
avant d'acquérir une certaine légitimité
et d'être complètement accepté le poids
de suivante c'est ne pas juger je suis
sorti de cette école et j'avais
l'impression que je savais je savait des
choses
j'étais ingénieur j'en savais plus que
d'autres qui avaient moins de diplômes
et je me disais ce qui en somme - ils
vont pas pouvoir me montrer la voie eh
bien c'était faux parce que ce que je ce
que je sais aujourd'hui c'est que ceux
qui font savent et ils savent aussi
comment améliorer ce qu'ils peuvent
faire différemment
ils savent le ils savent comment mais
ils n'arrivent pas à concrétiser
donc on est là pour aider à concrétiser
et quelquefois portait évidemment des
solutions plus directive est plus
nouvelle
mais ils savent et le dernier point
c'est ne pas répondre aux provocations
les provocations sont légion c'est
quelque chose qui est je dirais assez
difficile quelquefois un peu avoir des
attaques personnelles on peut avoir des
choses du genre mais ma pauvre ma pauvre
dame si vous criez pas plus fort comment
voulez-vous faire entendre dans ce
milieu là je n'ai jamais crié de ma vie
et je me suis fait entendre donc je
pense que c'est
c'est important aussi de ne pas répondre
aux provocations en résumé je dirais une
femme en production une forme de la
transformation de la production c'est
possible pour moi ça a été un grand
bonheur
quelques nuits blanches je crois
fermement que l'amélioration est en
voyage sans fin et d'ailleurs c'est mon
moto dans la vie merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]